president considered the final word by
the white house at least as
america's longest war draws down or does
the president
plan to mark this in some other way when
all of the troops are out
well jeff i would say that we we are uh
the president will continue to update
the american people as
commander-in-chief why he's making
choices
uh uh to that are in our national
security interest today is an example of
that
and today is an opportunity to
communicate again why he made the
decision he made
and communicate again why it's in our
interests so i'm not going to rule out
when
if he will or will speak on afghanistan
in the future in terms of plans
for the end of for our men and women
coming back
i don't have anything to preview but we
don't we're not going to have a mission
accomplished moment in this regard it's
a
20-year war that has not been won
militarily
we are proud of the men and women who
have served
incredibly grateful the president will
note that in his remarks today how
grateful he is for
their service and the families who have
sacrificed
uh over the last 20 years and we will
continue to press for a political
outcome and a political solution but
beyond that i think we're going to
continue to look for ways to communicate
why
we make the soy choices we make the
mission accomplished has this mission
not been accomplished
well i would say we did exactly what we
wanted to do what i was referring to
jeff is we're not having a moment of
celebration
uh we're having a moment where we feel
it's in our national security interest
to bring our men and women
serving home and we feel it's in our
national security interest
for uh afghan forces to be in the lead
we did exactly what we intended to do
and certainly that is
something thanks to the leadership of
our military we have achieved
however there is not benefit in our view
and continuing to fight this war
militarily
go ahead thank you jen if the military
would